we recall there's something like to
that's the base isn't it ^ 3 right but
it's really short 4 is 2 times 2 so
super good okay and then we noticed that
okay you can multiply numbers that have
the same base right for example 2 cubed
x to the power of 5 we saw you can do
just by writing out everything but
that's a really slow way of doing it
instead remember when you multiply
numbers at the same base you add these
sorry I just said multiply numbers are
the same you see I'm it same base just -
okay so it's ^ 8 good this is number one
definition number two multiplication yes
say what you cover was division and it
follows the same idea but in Reverse
right so if I had something like 3 to
the power of 9 divided by 3 power 4 okay
just like yeah just like multiplication
you guys to audition here division goes
to subtraction right so you take away
one D next from the other okay so
therefore you get through your turn five
okay but we noticed a few interesting
things here right because if you follow
this pattern through we've done this to
the tables before but now we can use
this law if you're lying that if I take
for example let's now go let's now get
algebra let's think about not just
specific numbers but any numbers we like
okay I think you might have remembered
this if you've got these two numbers
okay so a whatever it is a num you like
but the important thing is they're same
and then you got two numbers here right
just following the pattern from this
line what happens the base a what
happens there it stays the same right
and then what do you do with the indices
yep
who it okay so this is what we've got
but now consider what happens if m and n
are the same okay if I had this good
morning welcome back to class okay all
right now if the indices are the same we
look two ways to think about this right
two ways you could say first look it's a
number divided by itself right what's a
number any number divided by itself
divided by itself is 1 like 5 divided by
5 is 1 and 100 by behind draw is 1 okay
so you can say it equals 1 but in the
same way you can follow this guy see
what happens right the bases are the
same so what happens to the base it just
stays in and then you go to here you got
em - but both of the powers of same
right what's M might get a number
takeaway itself it's it's 0 right like 5
minus 5 is 0 3 minus 3 is 0 let's add
the power naught right but but these two
things came from the same place right so
that means they're the same as well but
that's that's my yeah that's right so
that's my conclusion okay what's your
question you mean no.5 naught is a no
it's 1 see this is my point
okay let me illustrate to you again I
can think about this slide here from two
angles I can say it's just a number
divided by itself right and whatever
that number is when you divide by itself
you just get one okay but alternatively
if I take what you guys learned
yesterday that when you divide numbers
of the same base you subtract the
indices then this is what you get okay
well if you go from the same thing you
get two different answers that means the
two answers at this
aim okay so that's why this is what you
want to put in a big colorful box okay
scaring the back then any number any
number there any number okay if you
raise it to the power of 0 or if it has
a zero index okay any number to the
power of 0 is 1 okay so this is this is
a if you like it's called an index law
just like all your other ones okay yeah
yeah it does look like a degrees hold on
two different questions there firstly it
does look like a zero sorry like a
degree sign there's not much way to
avoid I mean if I which in if you
actually typed it out the very very
subtle difference is that if it's a zero
it's slightly taller and a degree side
is meant to be perfectly circular
that's not perfectly circular but anyway
because it's about like angles going
around and around like in the circle
right so that's the difference but apart
from that the only thing yeah it depends
on the the context that surround them